[Music]
finally here we go
good evening here oh you have 576
possible web-shooter from the nation I
can keep that suit ya don't fit me
where's our next retreat
what next mission we'll call you all
right no no just grab the top for you
all right there yeah all right good good
luck out there tonight I can't tonight
I got the star Keaton ship what's up
guys here's my report for tonight I
stopped the grand theft bicycle hey
could you do me a favor hold on I helped
us old lady and she bought me a churro
so how was nice wait a minute you guys
aren't the real event just hope gives it
away new move I'm working on
these weapons are crazy dangerous listen
fear there people who handle this sort
of thing can't you just be a friendly
neighborhood spider-man
activating parachute
the world's changing boys it's time we
change to my chance to prove myself we
have a Spanish quiz you gotta get better
at this part of the job
where you going what are you hiding
Peter I'm just getting hungry bye
there's a ton of other social systems in
here but we're all disabled by the
training wheels protocol treating me
like a kid but you are a kid stop a boss
with his bare hands
[Music]